ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM BURNER* BATH
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DAILY.
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
NAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMóN OWN.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS THREE
OF US ROBERT REAVIS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE.
TEAM VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER WICKS.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE
STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OSHA EVER NOTION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
YESTERDAY BEING VALENTINE'S DAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO REFLECT ON
ROMANTIC LOVE.
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING FOR IN
SOMEONE TO LOVE? FOR ME IT WAS
TO FIND SOMEONE WHO MADE ME
LAUGH AND COULD LAUGH AT
THEMSELVES.
IT WAS ALSO ESSENTIAL THAT THIS
PERSON.
BE BOTH REASONABLE AND REAL. ONE
WHO WAS ABLE TO LOOK INTO THE
MIRROR OF REALITY AND RESPOND
WITH HONESTY. TO ME HUMOR AND
HONESTY.
ARE IRREPLACEABLE ELEMENTS TO
HELP US THROUGH THE LONG HAUL OF
MARRIAGE.
THEY ARE ESSENTIAL ELEMENTS TO
HELP US TO THE CHALLENGES THAT
LIFE WILL BRING OUR WAY.
I REMEMBER IN.
TWO THOUSAND THREE WHEN MY
HUSBAND BOB WAS ELEVATED. TO
LEAD ONE OF THE LARGEST AND THE
SECOND OLDEST TEMPLE IN THE
MAINLAND UNITED STATES.
I SAID TO HIM.
BOB. FOR SOMEONE WITH ABSOLUTELY
NO TACK.
YOU HAVE NOW MAXIMIZE YOUR
POTENTIAL.
THE LITTLE HESITATION.
AND A KNOWING SMILE HE RESPONDED.
PATTY.
I HAVE FAR EXCEEDED MY POTENTIAL.
ALTHOUGH.
I NOW SMILE A ROLL MY EYES MORE
THAN LAUGH OUT LOUD.
I NOTE HUMOR IN HONESTY OF WHAT
WE SHARE. FOR WITH HUMOR COMES
KINDNESS IN FOR GENUINE HONESTY
WE ARE ALWAYS GRATEFUL.
NO MORE ME DOWN TO WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WRASSE.
ISSUE WITH US IN THE PLEDGE.
PLEASE PLACE YOUR RIGHT HAND
OVER YOUR HEART.
READY BEGAN.
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
OUR STANDS. ONE NATION.
ARE YOU KNOW.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MOVING TO READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL THE
READING CLERK WILL BEGIN TO READ.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT
NINE AM ON ALL KEVIN MULLIN
MISTER BONTA MOVES IN MISTER
GALLAGHER SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE.
NINE INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE
TO BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
TODAY'S ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER. TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY HIS GUESTS WILL
BE SEATED AT HIS DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AND I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS COM LONGER DOVE.
BLOOM BONTA MCCARTY FLORA AND
BURKE TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MOVING TO GUEST INTRODUCTIONS.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO OUR COLLEAGUE MR
GALLAGHER WHO IS A VERY
IMPORTANT INTRODUCTION TODAY
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE MY VALENTINE'S FOR
THIS MORNING AND I HAVE MY
DAUGHTERS WITH ME --
KATHERINE AND MAGGIE CATHERINE
IS IN THE SEVENTH GRADE IN
MAGGIE'S IN THE FIFTH GRADE AND
SO THEY'RE JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME CATHERINE MAG
INTERCHANGEABLE.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE WILL
BE PASSED IN RETAINS.
AND MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
FILE ITEMS TWO THROUGH FOUR DOES
ANY MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY RELATIVE TO ABRAHAM
LINCOLN'S BIRTHDAY.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE IN
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS TO THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HI MOM MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE.
I FIFTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THIS CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
FIVE HI IS FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
AND SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FOR ICE FIFTY SEVEN NO
.
ZERO MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
THIS SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS.
MONDAY FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH IS
THE PRESIDENT'S DAY HOLIDAY.
TUESDAY FEBRUARY NINETEENTH
FLOOR SESSION WILL BE A ONE PM.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR REMOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY MISS
KAHN LOVER DAD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY.
I THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MADAM SPEAKER.
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF DOCTOR MICHELLE KING
WHO PASSED AWAY ON FEBRUARY
SECOND TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
DOCTOR KING WAS A RESIDENT OF
THE FIFTY FOURTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
DOCTOR KING WAS BORN ON MARCH
NINTH.
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE SHE GREW UP
IN A LARGELY MIDDLE CLASS AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN NEIGHBORHOOD OF
SOUTH LOS ANGELES.
HER MOTHER WORKED FOR THE COUNTY
AND HER FATHER WAS A LAWYER.
SHE ATTENDED LA UNIFIED SCHOOLS
INCLUDING PALISADES HIGH WHERE
SHE WAS A TOP STUDENT AND A
CHEERLEADER AND ONE OF THE FEW
BLACKS AT A SCHOOL WHOSE STUDENT
BODY WAS MAINLY WEALTHY AND WAY.
A GRADUATE OF UCLA.
MAJORING IN BIOLOGY SHE TAUGHT
SCIENCE AND MATH AT PORTER
MIDDLE SCHOOL IN GRANADA HILLS.
SHE WAS PROMOTED TO A
COORDINATOR FOR THE MATH SCIENCE
AND AEROSPACE MAGNET AT RIGHT
MIDDLE SCHOOL IN WESTCHESTER AND
THEN SERVED AS ASSISTANT
PRINCIPAL AND PRINCIPAL AT
HAMILTON HIGH SCHOOL IN CHEVY AT
HILLS.
ALSO IN THE FIFTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
IN JANUARY TWENTY SIXTEEN DR
KING BECAME LA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S FIRST.
FEMALE AFRICAN AMERICAN SUPER
INTENDANT WHO CHAMPIONED UNITY
AND COLLABORATION AMONG ALL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS TILL JULY.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SHE PASSED AWAY
AT FIFTY SEVEN AFTER FIGHTING
CANCER.
DR KING DESCRIBED HERSELF AS AN
LA U. S. D. LIFER.
SHE'S BEEN HER LIFE CAREER IN
THE DISTRICT AND ATTENDED
SCHOOLS EVEN WORKING AS A
TEACHER'S AIDE WHILE A STUDENT
AT PACIFIC PALISADES HIGH SCHOOL.
DR KING FELT THAT IF YOU GIVE
YOUNG WOMEN AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
THAT ANYTHING.
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
DOCTOR KING SAID SOMETIMES IN
LIFE WE DON'T THINK THAT CERTAIN
POSITIONS ARE AVAILABLE TO US
PARTICULARLY IF YOU'RE YOUTH A
MINORITY.
THAT JOB OR THAT POSITION OR
THAT ROLE MIGHT NOT BE FOR YOU
BECAUSE YOU DON'T SEE MANY ROLE
MODELS YOU DON'T SEE MANY FOLKS
IN THOSE POSITIONS.
AND SHE WORKED TO BECOME ONE OF
THOSE FOLKS IN THOSE POSITIONS.
HER LEGACY WILL LIVE ON IN THE
FIFTY FOURTH LAST YEAR THE GIRLS
ACADEMIC LEADERSHIP ACADEMY THE
FIRST ALL GIRLS STEM SCHOOL IN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM WAS RENAMED
THE DOCTOR MICHELLE KING SCHOOL
FOR SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY ENGLISH
AND MATH.
AND IT TOO IS LOCATED IN THE
HEART OF THE FIFTY FOURTH.
DOCTOR KING IS SURVIVED BY HER
DAUGHTERS BROTHER.
DR KING WILL BE MOURNED AND
MISSED BY HER FAMILY AND ALL WHO
KNEW HER.
THE C. L. BC THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IS
PRESENTING A RESOLUTION TODAY AT
HER GOING HOME CEREMONY.
PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY IN A
JOINING IN THE MEMORY OF DOCTOR
MICHELLE KING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMAGRA
DAD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS MOST
RESPONSIBLE FOR RUINING MY
SUMMER IN OCTOBER.
OF NINETEEN SIXTY SIX THAT'S
WHEN THE BALTIMORE ORIOLES SWEPT
THE LA DODGERS FOR GAME STRAIGHT
IT WAS FRANK ROBINSON IN THE
FOURTH INNING.
OF THAT FOURTH GAME.
WHO HIT THE ONLY RUN IN THAT
GAME -- THE
TOOK THE DODGERS DOWN TO DEFEAT.
FRANK ROBINSON WAS A LEGENDARY
BASEBALL PLAYER.
A HALL OF FAMER A BARRIER
BREAKER.
AND A CIVIL RIGHTS ADVOCATE.
ROBINSON IS THE ONLY PERSON TO
MOST VALUABLE PLAYER IN BOTH THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE.
AND THE NATIONAL LEAGUE IT'S AN
AMAZING ACCOMPLISHMENT.
HE WAS A TRAILBLAZER BOTH ON AND
OFF THE FIELD AND WAS THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN MANAGER.
IN MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
HE BEGAN HIS CAREER IN NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE AND MINOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL QUICKLY GRADUATED TO
THE MAJOR LEAGUES THREE YEARS
LATER.
STARTING A CAREER WITH THE
CINCINNATI REDS.
HE PLAYED FOR THE REDS FOR TEN
YEARS DURING WHICH HE WON HIS
FIRST MVP TROPHY.
AND IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX THAT
FATEFUL YEAR HE BEGAN PLAYING
FOR THE BALTIMORE ORIOLES WHERE
HE WOULD PLAY FOR SIX SEASONS
HELPING THAT TEAM GET THE TO THE
WORLD SERIES. FOUR TIMES OF
WINNING IT TWICE OVER THOSE
YEARS.
ROBINSON WENT ON TO PLAY FOR THE
DODGERS THE ANGELS AND THE
INDIANS AND DURING HIS LAST YEAR
WITH THE INDIANS ROBINSON TOOK
ON THE ROLE OF BOTH PLAYER.
AND MANAGER BECOMING THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN MANAGER OF A
MAJOR LEAGUE TEAM AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER --
I'D LIKE TO PUT THAT IN CONTEXT.
OF BECOMING THE MANAGER OF A
MAJOR LEAGUE TEAM.
WAS THE FUNCTIONAL EQUIVALENT OF
BECOMING THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN CEO OF A MAJOR
CORPORATION THIS IS A REALLY BIG
DEAL -- AND
YOU KNOW WE RIGHTFULLY LIONIZE
JACKIE ROBINSON FOR BREAKING THE
COLOR COLOR BARRIER IN BASEBALL
BACK IN.
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN IT WAS
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS LATER TALK
ABOUT THE ARC OF JUSTICE --
IT MOVES INCREDIBLY SLOWLY
SOMETIMES IT TOOK TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS FOR THERE TO BE AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN MANAGER MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL --
AND THAT WAS FRANK ROBINSON.
HE MANAGED DOUG HAD A LONG
CAREER MANAGING TEAMS INCLUDING
THE SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS THE
BALTIMORE ORIOLES IN THE
MONTREAL EXPOS.
HE WAS KNOWN TO BE A SKILLED
FOCUSED AND INTENSELY
COMPETITIVE PLAYER AND AT THE
TIME OF RETIREMENT.
HE HAD THE FOURTH HIGHEST NOTE
FOR AND THIS IS FROM THE FIELD --
HIS RETIREMENT FROM THE FIELD HE
HAVE THE FOURTH --
HOME RUNS AND ALMOST THREE
THOUSAND HITS.
ROBINSON WAS INDUCTED INTO THAT --
NATIONAL BASEBALL HALL OF FAME
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO ON THE
FIRST BALLOT IN HIS FIRST YEAR
OF ELIGIBILITY ANOTHER BIG DEAL.
A AND HE ALSO RECEIVED THE
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF FREEDOM IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HE PASSED AWAY
ON FEBRUARY SEVENTH AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTY THREE AND IS SURVIVED.
BY HIS WIFE BARBARA AND COAL HIS
SON FRANK AND HIS DAUGHTER TO
SHELL AND I US THAT WE HAD
TURNED IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR THIS ADJOURNMENT
A MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
FRANK ROBINSON WHO PASSED AWAY.
ONE WEEK AGO AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY THREE FRANK ROBINSON WAS
THAT TRUE TRAILBLAZER ON THE
BASEBALL FIELD AND A TRUE
INSPIRATION TO THE COMMUNITY OF
OAKLAND.
FRANK ROBINSON ATTENDED WEST
OAKLAND'S CLIMB IN HIGH SCHOOL.
HE ONCE JOKED THAT HIS QUICKNESS
CAME FROM BEING ONE OF TEN KIDS.
IF YOU WEREN'T QUICK YOU DIDN'T
EAT HE SAID.
GROWING UP ON MYRTLE STREET WEST
OAKLAND HIS FAMILY STRUGGLE. TO
MAKE ENDS MEET.
IN FACT NEVER OWNED HIS OWN
BASEBALL GLOVE UNTIL HE WAS.
FOURTEEN FRANK ROBINSON WAS A
TOUGH AND RESILIENT PLAYER.
HE CREDITED THAT STRENGTH TO
GOING ON FALL IN OAKLAND.
HIS INDUCTION INTO THE BASEBALL
HALL OF FAME HE TOLD THE STORY
OF SLIDING INTO SECOND BASE.
AND TEARING HIS PAT LAKE.
YOU CAME HOME IN HIS MOTHER WAS
DISTRESSED BY HIS TORN CLOSE BUT
HE SAID.
THAT SLIDING HARD WAS JUST HOW
THE GAME IS PLAYED.
NOTABLY IN THOSE DAYS FRANK WAS
PLAIN ON AN ASPHALT BASEBALL
FIELD.
RIPS IN THE SCRAPES ARE WHAT
MADE FRANK ROBINSON LEGENDARY
PLAYER.
AND MANAGER.
HE GREW TO BE.
IT ALSO HELPED HIM OVERCOME
STRUGGLES THAT CONTINUED WELL
INTO HIS PROFESSIONAL CAREER.
FRANK ROBINSON WAS ONE OF THE
LEAGUE'S MOST OUTSPOKEN PLAYERS
ON A VARIETY OF RACIAL JUSTICE
ISSUES.
AMONG THEM THE LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR WHITE
PITCHERS WHO THREW IT AT BLACK
HITTERS.
SOMETHING HE KNEW ABOUT ALL TO
WELL.
BEING ON THE RECEIVING END A
HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT TIMES.
THE SAME YEAR HE WAS NAMED MOST
VALUABLE PLAYER HE WAS ALSO
TURNED AWAY BECAUSE OF HIS RACE
WHEN HE TRIED. TO BUY A HOUSE.
HE WAS STOPPED AT THE DOOR OF A
PARTY CELEBRATING HIS TEAM'S
PENNANT WHEN BECAUSE OF A QUOTE
NO NEGROES ALLOWED AND QUOTE
SIGN.
STILL FRANK ROBINSON PERSEVERED
AND NEVER LET IS OBSTACLES TO
TURN HIM.
FROM BECOMING ONE OF THE
GREATEST PLAYERS IN THE HISTORY
OF BASEBALL.
HE WAS TRULY ONE OF A KIND.
THE SPIRIT OF WHAT MAKES OAKLAND
GREAT AND HIS POWERFUL LEGACY
EVER LET AS THE TERMINATION.
STRENGTH OF CHARACTER AND
INDOMITABLE WILL WILL CONTINUE
TO LIVE ON AS WE CONTINUE OUR
FIGHT FOR A MORE JUST AND MORE
FAIR SOCIETY.
THAT WAS SPEAKER MEMBERS ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF AND
IN SINCERE GRATITUDE TO FRANK
ROBINSON.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY WERE
ALSO RECOGNIZED FOR THIS A
GERMAN A MEMORY THANK YOU I ALSO
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE PASSING
OF FRANK ROBINSON.
I WITH A HEAVY HEART WE TALK
ABOUT HIM TODAY OUR MEMBERS THAT
YOUNG BOY MY DAD LIVED IN
OAKLAND.
AND I WAS TOLD ABOUT HIS OAKLAND
HISTORY IT'S AMAZING THAT ONE
HIGH SCHOOL BASEBALL TEAM HAD --
THREE FUTURE MAJOR LEAGUERS
FRANK ROB AND CURT FLOOD AND HE
WAS THE HEART OF OAKLAND AND OF
COURSE HE WAS THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN MANAGER I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THAT AS WE CELEBRATE.
BLACK HISTORY MONTH HERE IN
FEBRUARY AND HE REALLY IS ONE OF
THOSE UNSUNG HEROES WHO WHO MADE
A TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE.
IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA
SAID HE LEFT HIS MARK ON THE
BASEBALL FIELD MVP.
IN TWO LEAGUES WON THE TRIPLE
CROWN A FIRST BALLOT HALL OF
FAMER THE FIRST AT THE TIME --
BUT ALSO HE LEFT HIS MARK IN THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ERA BECAUSE IN THE
IN THE IN THE SIXTIES.
AND FRANKLY IN THE FIFTIES AND
AND THAT AREA WAS HARD FOR
ATHLETES TO STEP UP AND THEY
WERE ALL THERE OFTEN LOOKED DOWN
UPON IN THE AIR THAT WE SEE THAT
COLIN KAEPERNICK MOVEMENTS OF
TODAY.
HE STOPPED UP AND LEANED IN AND
SAID WHAT WAS WRONG WHEN HE
TRIED TO BUY A HOUSE.
IN BALTIMORE AFTER IS TRADED IN
HE AND HIS WIFE WERE TURNED DOWN
BECAUSE OF A RED LINING POLICIES
AND HE SAID THAT HE WANTED TO
COME OUT.
OF JUST COMPLAINING BUT STEP UP
AND JOIN THE LOCAL AND DOUBLE
ACP SPEAK OUT AS FAR AS THE
INJUSTICES THAT HE FELT HE HAD
AN OBLIGATION --
HE REMEMBER THE OBLIGATION
BECAUSE HE CAME INTO.
THE MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL
BUSINESS A FEW YEARS AFTER
JACKIE ROBINSON NO RELATION BUT
HE REMEMBERED BUT JACKIE
ROBINSON TALKED ABOUT WHEN HE
FIRST WAS A PLAYER.
AND THE IMPACT IT WOULD HAVE ON
FUTURE PLAYERS AS WELL AND HE
HAD AN OBLIGATION TO TO LEAD A
STANDARD THAT REALLY HELPS THOSE
BEHIND HIM.
SO WHEN HE WAS ABLE TO BECOME A
MAN IN THE MID SEVENTIES HE
REMEMBER THAT AND KNEW THAT HOW
HE ACTED UPON THIS JOB WOULD
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE
BEHIND THEM.
AND HE TOOK HIS JOB FOR THE
CLEVELAND INDIANS AND THE CLIP
ANY IT SAYS WE WILL GIVE YOU
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE TO
BECOME A MANAGER.
WHICH WAS LAUGHABLE COMPARED TO
WHAT OTHER MANAGERS MADE WHO HAD
THE SAME JOB BUT HE SAID YOU
KNOW WHAT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR ME FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS I
WILL TAKE THIS JOB AS A PLAYER
COACH. FOR JUST AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND HE'S
CERTAINLY LEFT ITS MARK --
OTHER BLACK MANAGERS CAME CAME
AFTER HIM HE WAS --
RECOGNIZED IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
WITH THE PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF
FREEDOM AND AS HE WAS --
WINDING DOWN IN HIS --
HEALTH IN --
IN YOUR DISTRICT.
HE DECIDED HE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL DONATIONS AND
MEMORIES --
WENT TO SOMETHING THAT WOULD
FOCUS ON HIS LEGACY SO HE ASKED
AT ALL --
DONATIONS AND END UP IN LIEU
EFFORTS GO TO THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MUSEUM IN WASHINGTON AND ALSO IN
MEMPHIS TO FOCUS ON THE EFFORTS
OF PEOPLE LIKE HIM.
AND HOW THEY INTER TODAY SO
THANK YOU AND WE ASK THAT WE
REMEMBER FRANK ROBINSON.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLOOR
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
WITH GREAT STATUS I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS.
SURRENDER G. DO GO ARE --
THREEA WHO PASSED AWAY.
JANUARY THIRTIETH.
SIR ENERGY WAS BORN IN INDIA IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE IT IS WHY
THE V. IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE HE MOVED
WITH HIS WIFE THREE CHILDREN TO
UNITED STATES IN.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE IN
ADDITION TO VOLUNTARY THE SIKH
TEMPLE HE OFTEN WORK DOUBLE
SHIFTS SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
HIS PROUDEST ACHIEVEMENT IN LIFE
FOR PUTTING HIS THREE CHILDREN
THROUGH COLLEGE THROUGHOUT HIS
LIFE.
HE PUT HIS FAMILY FIRST REMAINED
A LOYAL A LOVING HUSBAND FATHER
SON AND BROTHER.
HE ENJOYED COOKING NATURE
GARDENING WALKING HIS DOG.
PROVIDING FOR HIS FAMILY AND
SERVING HIS COMMUNITY HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS LOVING WIFE OF
THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
HIS SON TWO DAUGHTERS A SON IN
LAW AND HIS BROTHER.
HIS LIFE HIS LIGHT WILL LIVE ON
THROUGH HIS FAMILY MAY REST IN
PEACE AND WE'RE PROUD TO HAVE
YOU JOIN US TODAY SO OUR
CONDOLENCES TO MAKE ABORTION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
IT'S WITH A HEAVY HEART I RISE
TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF MY FRIEND
KEVIN LOVE ON BROWN.
BORN AND RAISED IN LOS ANGELES
KEVIN WAS WELL KNOWN IN THE
COMMUNITY AS AN ACTIVIST.
FROM A YOUNG AGE SHE WAS PASSION
ABOUT GETTING INVOLVED IN
WORKING WITH OTHERS FOR THE
COMMON GOOD.
AT AGE ELEVEN HE WAS IN WORLD IN
THE GUARDINO YMCA AND JOIN OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS JUNIOR
ACHIEVEMENT AND YOU THINK
GOVERNMENT.
AGE SEVENTEEN HE BEGAN WORKING
ON ELECTIONS AND CAMPAIGNS BY
GATHERING BALLOTS A COLLECTION
POINTS AND TAKING THEM DOWNTOWN
FOR PROCESSING.
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE KEVIN WENT
TO WORK FOR A CANDIDATE RUNNING
FOR LOS ANGELES CITY COUNCIL.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT HE WORKED
AS A VOLUNTEER DEPUTY FIELD
ORGANIZER ON SENATOR BARACK
OBAMA FOR CAN'T PRESIDENT
CAMPAIGN.
A TRUE GRASSROOTS EXPERIENCE
THOUSAND ELEVEN HE ORGANIZED
EARTHQUAKE RELEASED TRIP FOR
HAITI REDISTRIBUTED CLOTHING
SCHOOL AND MEDICAL SUPPLIES TO
OVER FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE.
INTO THOUSAND TWELVE HE WAS
ELECTED DELEGATE TO THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL PARTY FOR
THE REELECTION OF PRESIDENT
OBAMA.
AND HE WAS SUBSEQUENTLY INVITED
TO THE INAUGURATION FOR THE
PRESIDENT ELECT BARACK OBAMA AND
TO THE WHITE HOUSE FOR A
CHRISTMAS PARTY WITH THE OBAMAS.
ONE OF KEVIN'S FAVORITE SAYING
WAS EACH ONE TEACH.
ONE WHEN IT CAME TO ACADEMIC A
ACCESS AND ACHIEVEMENT HE
BELIEVE THE FASTEST ROUTE TO
CHANGE WITHOUT IN STRONG GROUP
DISCUSSION AND VIGOROUS DEBATE.
KEVIN WAS THE TRUE EMBODIMENT OF
WHAT IT MEANT TO LOVE YOUR
COMMUNITY.
HE WAS A TRUE ON THE GROUND
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE.
ON JANUARY THIRTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN KEVIN'S WORK
WAS FINISHED WHEN CALL GOD GOD
CALLED HIM HOME.
KEVIN DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO
GETTING PEOPLE LIKE ME ELECTED
BECAUSE HE KNEW HOW IMPORTANT IT
WAS FOR LITTLE KIDS TO SEE
PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE US.
IN GOVERNMENT.
KEVIN VOLUNTEERING GAVE ME HIS
TIME AND ENERGY TO MY ASSEMBLY
CAMPAIGN AND DURING THOSE MONTHS
WE GROUP TO BE GOOD FRIENDS.
A FACEBOOK POST KEVIN MADE ON
CHRISTMAS DAY PERFECTLY SUMS UP
WHO HE WAS [inaudible]
IT READ.
WISHING YOU ALL A MERRY
CHRISTMAS HAPPY HANUKKAH AND
WHATEVER HOLIDAY OR FESTIVAL YOU
CELEBRATE.
CALL SOMEONE TODAY HAVE COPY
WITH.
KNOCK ON A NEIGHBOR'S DOOR AND
SAY HI.
ASK A COLLEGE KID COLLEGE KID
HOW CLASSES ARE GOING.
GIVE A HOMELESS PERSON SOME
MONEY FOR LUNCH.
SAY A PRAYER THAT YOU MADE
ANOTHER YEAR.
LOVE YOU ALL.
I MISS MY FRIEND VERY MUCH AND
THE ENTIRE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
FEELS HAS LOS.
THANK YOU AND I ASSN WE ENTER IN
HIS MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
TO THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS TO JOURNEY
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAINED ON OCEAN
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR BONTA MOVES IN MISTER FLORES
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL TUESDAY FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH AT ONE PM